[Music]
this is Justin hey wolde reading Brett
Todd's review of agents of mayhem agents
of mayhem isn't what you'd call a subtle
game the single-player adventure from
Saints Row developer volition is all
about being larger-than-life with
intense superhero versus supervillain
combat and raunchy protagonists who drop
f-bombs almost as much as they drop real
bombs unfortunately the game doesn't
offer much more than a to the extreme
attitude which wears out its welcome in
record time you take on the role of the
titular agents of mayhem a group of
future superheroes that look and feel
like the r-rated offspring of the 80s GI
Joe cartoon and the agents of shield TV
show these agents float above the world
and a Helicarrier like fortress called
the Ark but you spend most of your time
with them on the battlegrounds of Seoul
South Korea a crisp and clean metropolis
dotted with sky-high towers it's there
you wage war against the League of evil
gentlemen intent on obliterating nation
the crystal encased in its shell has a
Dark Matter resonance more than
sufficient for the morning stars plans
basic elements of the story and setting
work well in establishing an initial
mood in place seoul's whitewashed future
tank and industrial design make it more
than just a battleground and while it's
a little too sterile to embrace the
quirkiness of something like Grand Theft
Auto 5s Los Santos it's still a
memorable location that feels alive in
its own over-the-top way agents tackle
Legion in three person squads although
they fight one at a time with you
swapping them in and out depending on
personal preference and the challenge at
hand squads can be fully customized on
the ark before missions there are a
dozen agents on the roster each with
skill and weaponry specialties that you
earn as you level up your heroes include
hardtack the hulking former naval
officer who totes a shotgun and has a
special harpoon attack in kingpin the
rapping gang leader with an SMG to name
just a few
try as they might to elicit a laugh the
agents fail to be likable character
this is in part due to the tired tropes
and stereotypes they embody but look
beyond their superficial flaws and it's
their dialogue along with most of the
writing and agents of mayhem that'll
make you cringe the most shoot don't
shoot look I don't have time the entire
game seems to have been scripted to the
taste of a 12 year old boy with non-stop
swearing and ceaseless one-liners
comprising the bulk of dialogue you want
me to get up don't you don't you insist
hard off before firing his mayhem minds
and cutscenes fall flat with jokes such
as hell yeah franchise force is back in
action franchise what now
franchise force I gave us a nickname
okay just give yourself a nickname at
least the villains are somewhat more
interesting than the heroes boss battles
feature the most engaging combat of the
entire game with gimmicks based around
each villains character and plot but
everything here still trips over failed
attempts at humor do not fret though
agent for I have a final present for you
I hope you got a get with you just you
weigh it first the explosive combat is
fun and impactful when you fire a
shotgun or detonate some mines or even
just launch an arrow you feel it but you
quickly get worn down by doing the same
things on repeat it doesn't take long
for the game's initially exciting
explosions to fade into the background
repetition is the hallmark of the actual
missions no matter what villain you
happen to be battling you fight through
the same corridors of the same
underground legion lair spread
throughout soul-killing the same
helmeted troopers over and over again in
most cases missions involve a lot of
pointless travelling across the city for
no apparent purpose aside from
stretching things out sometimes you have
to make your way to the tops of
buildings to keep things rolling again
for often no clear reason and the top
everything off bugs and glitches occur
with unfortunate frequency personality
can only take a broken and repetitive
game so far the attitude behind agents
of mayhem has potential in
east of its executed properly but
there's little to agents of mayhem
beyond it's foul-mouthed and bombastic
attitude it just pushes the game
integrating an obnoxious territory throw
in the poor mission design and bugs and
you've got a game with loads of mayhem
but not much else
what could need to be doing at the
planetarium they are building a secret
base on Uranus
[Music]